after two years of division and deadlock
Britain is now racing towards its
deadline in March to leave the European
Union in a conflict zone special this
week we look back at some of the key
arguments that have shaped this often
angry brexit debate who was telling the
truth and who wasn't
[Music]
one of the accusations against the leaf
side is that you consistently fail to
articulate what the British economy
would look like after brexit last
December we got a flash of real honesty
from Nigel Farage at the Oxford Union
when he said that I will accept that
none of us knows what the risks are if
we leave the European Union marvellous
the most momentous decision that the
British are being required to take in 40
years sort of fly with me and we'll see
what happens is if we put the X in the
Box in the right box on the ballot paper
we then have two years of hopefully a
responsible government hopefully a
responsible team that will negotiate a
an exit package which is this is a huge
gamble you want the British it's a huge
gamble for both sides the nervous time
for you coming up to the referendum so
nervous that you've even started to talk
about what it would be like to lose
haven't you well what I was actually
trying to do was say that the leave
campaign has made no attempt at all to
describe what a post
Drex at UK would look like so the
question I was raising was if we were to
vote to leave which I clearly hoped that
we weren't what would the mandate be
because there's a huge difference
between staying in the single market or
leaving it but why does you sense defeat
no I'm raising it now because I think
it's really important that when people
go to the ballot box on the 23rd of June
they understand what leave means and at
the moment there's a black hole where
they was doing kresteva if they vote
leave they know what they don't want
they don't want free movement they don't
want to massive contributions to the EU
and they don't want to be governed by
laws made in Brussels do that Chris Alex
it's got to be quite clear what they
don't want
precisely the point that if you and you
want to water that don't know I what I'm
saying is if the option on the table is
to stay in the single market like Norway
is not in the but in the single market
you have to accept free movement of
people and you have to pay into the EU
but that is that the leave campaign
oh is it isn't it well I the last I
looked they had 23 different models that
they've proposed you never stretched a
fact in this campaign in every campaign
some people have no I don't think I ever
did but some people on both sides used
good and bad arguments but you saw
people and vote leave using bad
arguments argument the whole country was
involved in this campaign so of course
they were good and bad arguments that's
not an excuse for misleading people is
it I don't think I've misled it what
about your campaign leading right of the
campaign some people who were
campaigning for leave out use bad argue
committee dumps you bring them in did
you want to rein them in well in life we
are responsible for what we do right
we're not responsible for every ally who
might have reached the same position as
us your vote leave campaign oh and I see
campaign I wanted you only weekly care
strategy assess the strategy you had on
Saturday please do well here are a
number of things that were said during
the campaign that I think may now be
fairly decried as false we were told
that there would be an emergency budget
that that have to be emergency tax rises
we're now being told will be tax cuts we
were told that our immigration officers
that the French government is
responsible for what the other side said
I'm only not going to hold you
responsible for what you said let's deal
first with with what appear to be
radically conflicting claims by you and
other leading lights in your campaign
right after the vote you caused
something of a stir on television by
saying that you favored the free
movement of workers to and from the UK
it means free movement of labour you
said it doesn't mean you citizenship my
question is at what point did you
declare in the campaign vote brexit
it'll mean free Mazar out at every mayor
every give me one example if you'll
allow me to I will take yes on that very
program sitting around that very table
with that very same interviewer at the
star
the campaign I had said exactly the same
thing I written a book called why vote
leave which sets it all out which sold
20,000 copies I hardly think like me
accusing this people mean free labor yes
it does we you need first of all the
triggering of article 50 by the
government of Mrs May and the proposal
the basic idea that I have in this
negotiation is not to destroy European
Union in this exercise because what the
British want was some of the British
people one because 48% have voted we
made other New Year but what a
government one is to make splits between
the freedoms in Europe freedom of goods
freedom of services freedom of capital
what they want to do is to make a split
between these three freedoms and the
freedom of movement of people and we
shall never accept that the unity of the
four freedoms for all citizens is a key
element in the example is negotiating
and saying we will never accept that so
where are the negotiations now we will
never accept to undo the European Union
you cannot expect that if the British
people or majority of the British people
want to go out of the European Union
that we shall destroy the European Union
I have to defend the interests of
European citizens that I have to defend
the interest of the German citizens the
Belgium citizens who want to keep the
European Union because it's in their
advantage that let's this European it's
their work is a job talk about that what
is happening the central issue is what
is more important the single market or
freedom of movement prime minister to
resume say has said migration from the
EU will be cut so what will happen you
say anything what will happen what she
wants is very clear she has announced it
and becomes of this party convention a
few weeks ago she announced that she
wants a a kind of free trade agreement
with the European Union so that will be
the negotiation but what we don't will
never a negotiation when one side is
saying never no no it's about a very
it's about a free trade agreement what
what we don't
what we shall never accept is to undo to
destroy the internal market to destroy
the European Union by saying to the
people okay
freedom of movement is not longer a
basic principle of the Union let's be
honest the freedom of movement is key
for European the freedom of travel the
possibility for for German people to
work into another country that is the
key of your life
we will never destroy what again never
destroyed so where is the negotiation
case these are saying very clearly we
don't want to have that no and that's
the reason why I do want to leave the
European Union that's the point and the
question is now what is the new
relationship between the European Union
and Great Britain once Great Britain has
left the European Union and that will be
the topic of the negotiation hand on
your heart is the you even going to
exist in five years times I'm saying yes
time absolutely as it is now as it is
now even stronger with the same members
having in mind that five years ago we
had the economic crisis in Europe we
have still an economic crisis Ehlinger
it's still a big challenge we are today
stronger we are today CD Great Britain
laugh having the rx-8 France having
election you will see that the brexit
will lead at the end to a situation
where people understands how important
this union is because today not Berlin
in Paris as a problem is practice it
London has a big problem is what I'm
saying here is this it would be a bad
thing for the peoples of Europe if the
political class of Europe willfully go
for a bad deal with Britain because they
want to punish us they want to
discourage other people from leaving the
club and I do not think that across much
of Europe that the political elites are
held in any high degree of regard so you
can certainly accuse me of attacking the
European elites but my goodness me
they've given me some - all right hear
this from the German car manufacturers
you told everyone in Britain of course
the Germans will never allow tariffs to
be slapped on their car exports to brick
they wouldn't want it they wouldn't want
it okay so what did Chancellor Merkel
tell the world she said the internal
cohesion of the EU would come before
defending
German exports to the UK the association
of car manufacturer says the future of
the EU is more important than short-term
exports would you know what this
actually plays into my hands even more
this gives me an EVE this gives me an
even bigger card that I thought I had to
play because here is my card
oh come on the relationship between big
business big banks and big politics is
what it is they don't want things to
change they like the status quo the way
that it is but I bet you that if we went
to a bar in Munich this evening and met
some German car workers and had this
conversation what they care about are
their jobs what they care about are cars
be may be better there we go your route
just for that I'm not talking to the
bosses I'm talking to the European
they're the ones who make the decisions
want to tell you something actually
they're backing wrong and let me tell
you why you're wrong we are due to leave
the European Union at the end of March
19 okay
the European elections take place a few
weeks later what I want to try to do
there's no guarantee of success what I
want to try to do is to make sure that
those MEP s who are up for re-election
are asked by their electorates are you
going to vote for a sensible trade deal
are you going to vote for our jobs
because you know one thing's for certain
there are 1.3 million people in Germany
whose jobs rely on exports to the UK
market
what happens if it all goes wrong I mean
we haven't even started the negotiation
you you said in 2015 you said in 2015 at
the Oxford Union none of us knows what
the risks are if we leave the European
Union none of us knows what the risks
are if we stay in the euro so we were
left to just you know take your bravado
and you're it's very simple and your
assurance very simple we're left to do
that very simple you could never predict
the future exactly whatever side of the
referendum or a team is using you UK
anyone that thinks he knows the future
should be retired go they should have
better afford to do you know and the
real question with that referendum
was should we be responsible as a nation
with its own identity for making the key
decisions that determine our future and
whether we get them right or get them
wrong genuinely once every four or five
years have the chance to hold to account
the people who took those decisions or
do we think our future better to be a
small voice as part of a bigger new
state and now I've been as you know
objective about that as I possibly can
be that's what the referendum was about
and what we opted for not by a massive
knowledge of what we opted for was
making their own decisions and steering
our own ship and that I believe to be
right in all circumstances here's a
context which is really important we've
said that at the end of this process
when people know what the brexit deal
what leaving the European Union might
look like when we've got a few answers
that we don't have at the moment then
you give the people of Scotland a choice
and what's been fascinating it's a way
that that has been embraced by
politicians across the European
institutions and across Europe as well
as elder party is almost completely
United around the process of leaving the
European Union and also by the way on
leaving but it's the mechanics
oh she a ssin excuse me do you know the
outcome of negotiations my point is you
negotiate that's what you do you
negotiate with the European Union
European Union and peers to know what it
wants this government does you say
actually I did read the other day there
are a number of people in the europe
union they don't agree with the
Commission for example I think it was
the Austrian Finance Minister and may be
wrong about exactly what job he holds or
maybe it was a commissioner I can't
remember that he actually said quite
clearly that he thought the UK was an
incredibly strong position because the
European Union needed the trade we've
also had the fine he's the only one
isn't he he's the only finish the
finance minister of a very election mrs.
Merkel the other day about making sure
that she didn't screw up the
negotiations because there were a
million and a half jobs in Bavaria lie
on exports to the UK or machine tools
and cars alone there are plenty o as I
talk to a lot of European businesses I
was talking to a person the other day
that does low tech product he's a
Belgian manufacturer he produces
potatoes and he said the last thing we
need in Europe is a
tariff wall because my business would go
down the tubes I employ lots of people I
said have you spoken to your politicians
he said we're talking to them now so
before we just get this out of kilter
the European Union is in a position
where they're not all together
completely United and they also
recognize that they do need a trade deal
more about trade doesn't you do
something about this trade deal alright
stop interrupting me and just let me
tell you about a trade deal all right
you might learn something here's what
has to happen as we leave the European
Union we will also reenter the WTO as a
voting member we're a member but we're
not a voting member now the schedules
that are owned by the EU actually have a
financial tag to them so unless they
agree with us the amount of money that
we pay to take some of those schedules
relevant to us and lodge them at the WTO
they will end up as the EU spending a
great deal more money for Less potency
now here's the point they have to settle
that that's not they might they have to
settle that at the time we leave
otherwise they pick up a bigger bill so
mr. Barney a knows very well that until
this for example is settled nothing is
settled we all we are there's no point
in revisiting history
there's no demands in the country for a
further general election what there are
demands for from I know from standing on
doorsteps in my constituency is for the
UK government to proceed with the
negotiations and end up with the best
possible brexit deal so that's why all
these things should be very much
explored but my point is this in trying
to get a solution that placate both
remain errs and brexit ears Britain
seems to be reduced to putting forward
ideas that are pretty much unworkable is
that really the best your party can do
well I think that all options have to be
on the table and objective well I think
the understanding is understanding
obviously why things are rejected look
the brexit referendum has been hugely
divisive in this country and I do think
one of the mistakes made early on was
not trying to acknowledge that whilst
the leave campaign and 116 million
people 48% of those who voted had not
voted for this
to bring people together to explain that
we would be leaving but we would do it
in a way that was not going to damage
completely unnecessarily people's own
livelihoods and our economy that's what
we're sort of catching up to now that's
what I expect to be debated both in
Parliament and in cabinet in the next
few weeks looking back over the last two
years you were part of David Cameron's
cabinet which approved this referendum
why did none of you ever ask the kinds
of basic questions that people are
grappling with now what if what if we
lose the referendum what if the body
splits what if Europe applies the rules
what about the Northern Ireland border
why were none of these questions thought
about beforehand well I can't say they
weren't they weren't thought about well
partly because I've obviously many of us
campaigned in order to remain and it's
difficult if you're campaigning for one
thing to gaze into the crystal ball and
answer every question that's going to
come up I deeply regret the result but
the result is we in this country
obviously had a fair and democratic vote
difficult very difficult for people to
accept but I think it is the right thing
to do to balance those two now which is
to say yes we are going to leave the
European Union but we're not going to do
it in a way that's damaging and if we
constantly look back to the past and
read if the vote from two years ago that
actually I think what happens is that
attention is not given so that future
relationship between the two parties
which is very important power as we call
it Western system of democracy rule of
law parliamentarism
is under stress what happened in UK UK
them the origin of modern
parliamentarism moved the most important
decision in for the first decades in
this century from UK from Westminster to
a referendum crazy there seems to have
been a sense in France that this was
really just a British problem and France
could get perhaps some profit out of it
but that's changing now isn't it it's
not just a question of wanting Britain
to suffer although mr. macron
suggested that he thought they should
suffer didn't he
no he said I mean and Rex it shows us
one thing it's not easy to access its
exit the European Union not without cost
not without consequences is that false
well he wanted the suggestion is that he
wanted blow to pay that suggested it no
the suggestion is imagine a [ __ ] [ __ ]
meaning the EU is a complicated process
I don't mean that anybody on either side
of the channel would deny that would you
do know do you know anybody who would
actually say that the the process of
leaving the EU is an easy one well
actually some people in this country in
Britain certainly said it was an easy
one but they've been proved wrong do you
believe in a last-minute deal the two
sides taking it right down to the wire
just to show that they've extracted all
the concessions I'd like and like the
others
I just like to make a point there is no
one including the president in France
who thinks that brexit is a good thing
but there is a strong feeling in London
that the French wanted maximum
uncertainty for as long as possible
the one thing to try and persuade
British based finance houses into moving
into continental Europe no we've been
very very clear from the from the get-go
about what was important to France we've
just talked about Europe we consider
that the European single market is the
future of our economy we were very clear
there is one key red line which is any
deal cannot undermine that single market
my question was do you believe in the
last-minute deal because it seems that
Monsieur bond EA is softening some of
his positions on Northern Ireland and on
financial services I think we should do
everything in our power to find a deal I
think not having a deal would be if not
disastrous at least very hurtful for
both parties so I think we should work
absolutely consistently would one
objective in head to find a deal at any
price and it doesn't come at the price
of undermining the semantics your
populist movement has already in the
United States by lightening up white
supremacists there are numbers of their
organization and with
Rex it in Britain has created enormous
damage to the social fabric it's led to
bitter political polarization because
you've been looking for people's
grievances and anger and you want to
stir it up I want I want to tell you
that the biggest damage you dangerous
biggest damage just wait the biggest
damage has been created by the elites or
the so-called elite to the ordinary guy
for the last 20 or 30 years look at the
social fabric as it is existing today
look at the social fabric for example in
France and so on look at the social
fabric you know in the small English
English cities for example we are not
bringing we are not bringing damages
well bring damages to the social fabric
we are bringing damages to delete to the
establishment as it is today that is
true and we are threat to them and the
polarization didn't exist before really
you can make it worse no you can only
make things we are probably our stomachs
we are to contend to represent the
ordinary guy ok that has been so so long
despised and forgotten by these elites
and indeed we are we have the populist
from all over the world the voice of
this ordinary guy I would invite Angela
Merkel to follow up her offer to be
compromising why should they look again
in the deal when it said they've already
said this is the only deal on offer so
that you can come back again in a couple
of months and try to alter it again well
I mean there's been no consistency from
the British side has I don't think the
British side has negotiated particularly
clearly and I do to some extent
sympathize with our European partners
that Teresa Mayer's government hasn't
been very clear because of internal
divisions within the within the
government Parliament has legislated
that we're leaving on the 29th of March
now Parliament's being clear about what
it doesn't want us to be clear about
what it does want
well Parliament is so far rejected that
withdrawal agreement but it hasn't
rejected the leave date of the 29th of
March and it remains to be seen whether
it does so but to the EU there's very
little point in negotiating with someone
who manifestly does not have a mandate
for the deal she's already agreed let
alone anything else in the future well
she has a mandate as as does the House
of Commons as a whole to leave the
European Union to fulfil the referendum
result and as I keep repeating the law
is now quite clear in the United Kingdom
and indeed in the European Union
we're leading on that date now there are
people in the House of Commons who are
trying to change their decision change
the decision of Parliament they are
assuming that the European Union will
automatically provide some extension to
article 50 I imagine the European
Union's going to want to ask what for
why are you extending article 51 of the
draft proposals extends article 50 for
nine months do you really want the
United Kingdom to take part in the
European Union elections to the European
Parliament when we're planning to leave
the European Union just nine months
later you've been saying that No Deal is
increasingly attractive but that's not
what you and your vocal Eve colleagues
promised the country was it I mean time
and again they promised great deals with
the EU and everyone else and said they
they just fall into Britain's lap didn't
they turned out to be nonsense well I
have to confess that I think it's in the
European Union's interests to strike a
sensible free-trade deal with the United
Kingdom and whether we make that
agreement before we leave which looks
rather unlikely now or after we leave I
believe that that's what will happen but
in the end my point is that we need
broken promises weren't well where the
vote leave campaign didn't make promises
we were campaigning
where your fellow brexit err and an
erstwhile brexit secretary David Davis
constantly boasted that both Britain's
exit terms and a new free trade
agreement would be
trapped within the article 50 timeframe
that hasn't gone so well he said at the
end of two years soon in 2016 in the end
of two years he said we will have our
deals you don't have well I think there
was definitely overconfidence there but
I think it wasn't helped by the fact
that Theresa May couldn't bring the
cabinet together to agree what they were
going to ask for and then in and then
started asking for a much more
complicated arrangement than I think
that president tusk was originally
offering at March last last year and
then the whole Irish border question has
been conflicted as a mechanism to try
and split the United Kingdom which in a
way that's completely unacceptable I
don't know why the Prime Minister ever
accepted the premise of that discussion
very jenkin could tell your own
conflicts I thank you thank you very
much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you